I apologize to listeners. That's the title of the episode. I apologize to listeners. It goes with your credenza. It does go with my credenza. The bed frame and the credenza are both walnut. Listeners, I really love walnut. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 41, recorded on September 1st, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we have a casual catch-up where we talk about credenzas, walnuts, bagels, bialis, and so much more.
我向听众道歉。这就是本期节目的标题。我向听众道歉。它和你的餐具柜很搭。它确实和我的餐具柜很搭。床架和餐具柜都是胡桃木的。听众们，我真的很喜欢胡桃木。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 41 期，录制于 2021 年 9 月 1 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯进行了一次随意的闲聊，我们聊了聊餐具柜、胡桃木、百吉饼、比亚利面包等等。
If you're only interested in technical content, feel free to skip this episode. Holy smokes, ladies and gentlemen. Bryce has decided to join. I had to unpack the microphone in my defense. In your defense. Then I had to reassemble the microphone in my defense in your defense and i had to then i had to reassemble the microphone stand and and let me tell you while the blue yeti is a very good microphone the microphone stand does not live up to price standards it's like impossible to get it like
如果你只对技术内容感兴趣，请随意跳过这期节目。天哪，女士们先生们。布莱斯决定加入了。为了辩解，我不得不打开麦克风。为了你的辩解。为了辩解，然后我不得不重新组装麦克风，为了你的辩解，然后我不得不重新组装麦克风支架，而且我要告诉你，虽然蓝雪人（Blue Yeti）是一款非常好的麦克风，但这个麦克风支架完全不符合布莱斯的标准，简直不可能调到
really tight what else oh and then the freaking pop filter that you made me get which some people have some people have said oh i can't wait until price gets a pop filter guess what i have a pop filter my voice is just very crack and poppy oh i guess we're gonna have to bleep that explicit content don't worry i'll put like i'll put a little duck quack in there crack yes um but so the pop filter that you made me get there's no obvious place to attach this pop filter to the microphone and then finally i get the thing assembled and i'm like well i don't have any i i have no functional furniture in my manhattan apartment i have i have a very expensive designer credenza and like that's the least functional piece of my
非常紧。还有什么？哦，还有你让我买的那个该死的防喷罩，有些人曾说过，哦，我等不及看布莱斯用防喷罩了。你猜怎么着？我有一个防喷罩。我的声音就是有很多杂音和爆音。哦，看来我们得把不当内容消音了。别担心，我会加一点鸭子叫的声音进去。杂音，对。嗯，不过你让我买的那个防喷罩，没有明显的地方可以把这个防喷罩装到麦克风上。最后我把东西组装好了，心想，好吧，我在曼哈顿的公寓里没有任何功能性家具。我有一个非常昂贵的设计师款餐具柜，而那居然是我家里
furniture that was of course the one the first piece to arrive i have two two counter stools and i have um a bed but not not not not the bed that i ordered i have like a hundred dollar bed frame that i ordered because the bed that i ordered doesn't show up until january wait so pause pause for me and probably 95% of our listeners. What is a credenza? I mean, this is coming from, this is not me. Bryce, for those of you, I think he's mentioned it. He orders his cocoa from like, you know, some factory in the northern Alps of whatever.
最没有功能性的家具。当然，那也是第一件送到的家具。我有两张吧台凳，还有一张床，但不是我订的那张床。我买了一个价值一百美元的临时床架，因为我订的那张床要到一月份才送货。等等，暂停一下，为我和大概 95% 的听众解释一下。什么是餐具柜（credenza）？我的意思是，这不是我说的。布莱斯这个人，我想他提过，他从北方阿尔卑斯山某个地方的工厂订购可可。
That's a Sherpa takes it down off the mountain and then, you know, gets, you know, ferried across, blah, blah, blah. So it's actually British. Whatever. Close enough. You get your cocoa from a different continent. You don't know what a credenza is? I've never even heard the word credenza.
夏尔巴人把它从山上背下来，然后，你知道的，用渡船运送，巴拉巴拉。所以它其实是英国的。随便啦。差不多就行了。你的可可来自另一个大陆。你居然不知道什么是餐具柜？我甚至连“餐具柜”这个词都没听说过。
If I had to guess i would i would guess although i might not guess this because i do happen to know most of like the ferrari or lamborghini names but it sounds like a like an elite like mclaren type like name of a car like the ferrari credenza 2021 you know it's like you know what like they're also called like a sideboard or a buffet a buffet i've heard of those where you show up and you get all the different options or it's like a wedding option do you want the you want the plated you know 69 ahead or do you want the buffet 59 different that's a different a different type of buffet. A credenza, it's like a dining room cabinet.
如果让我猜的话，我可能会猜——虽然我可能不会这么猜，因为我恰好知道大多数法拉利或兰博基尼的名字——但它听起来像是一个精英阶层的迈凯伦那样的汽车名字，比如 2021 款法拉利餐具柜，你知道的，就像……哦，它们也被叫做边柜或餐具自助柜。餐具自助柜？我听说过这个，就是你去那儿挑选各种不同的选项，或者就像婚礼上的选项一样，你是想要每位 69 美元的盘装菜，还是想要每位 59 美元的自助餐？那是另一种不同的自助餐。餐具柜就像是一个餐厅储物柜。
So it's a cabinet type of thing that you'd put in your dining room to store, you know. It's mostly like a display piece, but like you might store your fancy dishes and points you can also use them as like a tv stand um uh which is what i will potentially be doing with my credenza although i wouldn't actually put a tv on my credenza because that would be like that would be a real crime i'm sure it could probably support supported tv but it's like spanish and it's all walnut it's very nice i'm very happy with it i feel like i'm gonna i'm gonna do the first adsp twitter poll do you know have you heard of have you heard of or do you know what a credenza is is it c-r-e-d-e-n-z-a course. Of course every civilized person knows what a credenza is. Jeez, look at that privilege just oozing out of your pores.
所以它是一种你可以放在餐厅里用来存放东西的柜子。它主要算是一件展示品，但你可能会把精美的餐具放在里面，或者……你也可以把它当作电视柜来用。嗯，这可能是我对我的餐具柜做的事，虽然我实际上不会在餐具柜上放电视，因为那样做就真的是犯罪了。我确信它大概能支撑一台电视，但它是西班牙产的，全都是胡桃木的，非常漂亮，我对此非常满意。我觉得我要发起第一次 ADSP 推特投票：你知道、听说过或知道什么是餐具柜吗？是叫 c-r-e-d-e-n-z-a 吗？当然。
Every civilized person knows what a credenza is. Look at this guy. Moves to New York. It's been, what, like a week? And just this nyaka. I'm walking here. I got my credenza. I got my bed frame.
每个文明人都知道什么是餐具柜。天哪，看看那种优越感从你的毛孔里渗出来了。每个文明人都知道什么是餐具柜。看看这家伙。搬到纽约才多久？也就一个星期左右吧？就变成这样一个纽约客了。“我正走在这儿呢。我有我的餐具柜。我有我的床架。”
It's being ordered and going to show up in the next. No, no, no, no. This bed frame is just the temporary bed frame that costs like $100. But it looks good for like $100 bed frame. Like it looks good. But the actual one is back ordered until January. But I fell in love with it so i'm gonna you gotta wait for the good stuff you gotta wait for the good stuff it goes with your credenza
它正在订购中，将在接下来的一段时间内送到。不，不，不，不。这个床架只是个临时床架，只花了一百美元左右。但作为一百美元的床架，它看起来挺不错的。看起来确实不错。但真正的那个要缺货到一月份。不过我一眼就爱上它了，所以我要……你得为好东西等待，你得为好东西等待。它和你的餐具柜很搭。
it does go with my credenza the bed frame the bed frame and the credenza are both walnut listeners i really love walnut usually i'd say if you're gonna get me a gift get me consumable things because i live in a small apartment um and so like things that i can eat or like you know stuff stuff stuff that i don't have to think about storing but if you do want to get me something uh uh you know more permanent you can't go wrong with walnut. It is my favorite wood. I know it's not one of the higher-end woods. It's actually one of the less expensive woods, which is why you can get almost anything in walnut. But I just love walnut furniture.
它确实和我的餐具柜很搭。床架，床架和餐具柜都是胡桃木的。听众们，我真的很喜欢胡桃木。通常我会说，如果你要送我礼物，送我消耗品就行，因为我住在一个小公寓里，嗯，所以比如我可以吃的东西，或者……你知道的，不用我去考虑存放问题的东西。但如果你确实想送我一些……嗯……更永久的东西，选胡桃木准没错。它是我最喜欢的木材。我知道它不是那种高端木材。它其实是比较便宜的木材之一，这也是为什么你几乎能买到任何用胡桃木做的东西。但我就是喜欢胡桃木家具。
I just really love it. And in fact, I had a conversation with my decorator where I was like, do I have too much walnut? Of course I have a decorator. Do you not have a decorator? How do you decide what furniture to purchase if you don't have a decorator? Oh my God. I had a conversation with my decorator where I was like, am I ordering too much walnut furniture for this apartment? Because there's a walnut bed. My coffee table, which is the one piece of furniture that I took from California, is walnut. My desk is walnut. The credenza, of course,
我就是真的很喜欢。事实上，我和我的室内设计师有过这样一段对话：“我是不是买太多胡桃木了？”我当然有室内设计师。难道你没有室内设计师吗？如果你没有室内设计师，你是怎么决定买什么家具的？哦，天哪。我和我的室内设计师有过一次对话，当时我说：“我是不是给这套公寓买太多胡桃木家具了？”因为有一张胡桃木的床。我的茶几——我从加州带走的唯一一件家具——是胡桃木的。我的书桌是胡桃木的。餐具柜，当然，
is walnut. The nightstands for the bed are walnut the dresser is walnut yeah so like pretty much all my furniture except for the bookshelves and the couch are walnut i really love walnut really really it's my favorite wood and so yeah i may have i may have gone a little bit overboard in the walnut and i may have too much walnut but um it's okay. It's okay. I have other ways to bring out the roots. Some accent blankets and rugs and pillows. Yeah, it'll be okay. Bryce and I, if you've been listening since episode zero, we do share a lot in common.
也是胡桃木的。床头柜是胡桃木的，梳妆台也是胡桃木的。所以，基本上我所有的家具，除了书架和沙发，全都是胡桃木的。我真的很喜欢胡桃木，真的真的很喜欢，它是我最喜欢的木材。所以，是的，我可能在胡桃木上有点过头了，我可能拥有了太多的胡桃木，但是……没关系。没关系。我有其他方法来调和这些色调。比如一些点缀用的毛毯、地毯和靠垫。是的，会没事的。布莱斯和我，如果你从第零期开始收听的话，我们确实有很多共同点。
We first started programming in high school, both on a TI and TI basic on a TI calculator. Love algorithms. Bryce was kicked out of university. I arguably was kicked out of a university, depending on how you want to spin it. This is where we draw the similarity line. And so Bryce with his accent, pillows and carpets and credenza and decorator, everything in my apartment, except for my mattress, was acquired from other people. My desk is a friend's brother's that he
我们都是在高中开始编程的，都是在 TI 计算器上使用 TI 和 TI Basic。热爱算法。布莱斯被大学开除了。可以说我也被一所大学开除了，这取决于你怎么看待它。这就是我们划定相似点的地方。所以布莱斯带着他的靠垫、地毯、餐具柜和室内设计师……我公寓里的所有东西，除了床垫，都是从别人那里弄来的。我的桌子是一个朋友的兄弟打算扔掉不要的。我的沙发、电视、茶几是我姐姐搬到卡尔加里时给我的。我现在大概有八九株植物。这些全都是我姐姐……
was going to throw away. I got my couch, my TV, my coffee table from my sister when she moved to Calgary. I have like eight or nine plants now. Those are all from my sister, my coffee table from my sister when she moved to Calgary. I have like eight or nine plants now. Those are all from my sister slash my other friend that just moved back to Vancouver. I do not have a decorator. You would be very... I can connect you with my decorator. I do not need a decorator. No, that is not something... I think you would be... My walls are completely blank blank i don't have anything hanging on yeah i have been noticing that and i've been needing to have a conversation with you about why you need to get you some art we don't need to the art is the the trees outside it's beautiful go for a run
我姐姐给的，还有另一个刚搬回温哥华的朋友。我没有室内设计师。你会非常……我可以把我的室内设计师介绍给你。我不需要室内设计师。不，那不是……我觉得你会……我的墙壁光秃秃的，什么都没挂。是的，我注意到了，我一直想跟你聊聊为什么你需要挂点艺术品。我们不需要。艺术品就是外面的树木，很美，去跑步吧。
no your walls are um your walls are it looks like a crime scene man we're gonna have to call this episode just a casual catch up for the first like little 20 minutes here because this is not sure the content that our listeners
不，你的墙壁……你的墙壁看起来就像一个犯罪现场，伙计。我们得把这期节目在前二十分钟左右直接叫做“随兴闲聊”，因为这肯定不是我们的听众想要的内容。
I'm sure they'll appreciate it anyway so how's the for those of you that haven't clued in bryce is now in new york um the move is done how did it go uh no no the move is not done i am in the apartment but as we've established i only have a bed a temporary bed frame mattress, two counter stools, and a credenza. My stuff from California has not yet arrived. And my furniture will be trickling in throughout September and October. And then the bed will arrive in January.
我相信他们不管怎样都会喜欢的。那么，对于那些还没反应过来的听众，布莱斯现在在纽约了，搬家已经完成了，进展如何？呃，没有，没有，搬家还没完成。我在公寓里，但正如我们已经确定的，我只有一张床、一个临时床架、床垫、两把吧台凳和一个餐具柜。我从加州运来的东西还没到。我的家具会在整个九月和十月陆续送达。然后床会在一月份到达。
So I won't really be fully moved in until like at least october when all the furniture gets here and then the bed is just sort of like you know one day they come and take the old bed out and then the next day they'll come and bring in the new bed so yeah i'm still sort of in the middle of moving because i don't have any stuff that sounds awful i hate moving yeah i mean i hate moving and i i i wish that uh that stuff was not going to take so long to arrive but like i had to decide between like getting stuff that was in stock or getting the stuff that i wanted and of course you know which choice i would make people at the store are like, oh, but that's going to take until January. And I'm like, okay. Yeah.
所以我直到十月份所有家具都运到之后，才算真正完全搬进去，然后床的事就有点像，你知道的，有一天他们来把旧床搬走，然后第二天他们把新床送来。所以，是的，我基本上还在搬家中，因为我没有什么家具。听起来太糟糕了，我讨厌搬家。是的，我是说我讨厌搬家，我希望那些东西不用花那么长时间才能送到，但我不得不在“买现货”和“买我真正想要的东西”之间做出选择，当然你知道我会怎么选。店里的人说：“哦，但这要到一月份才能到。”我说：“好吧。”是的。
But no, it's going good. Yeah, I've been here just a week now. Having meals with a bunch of various C++ folks. I had dinner with Alistair, the former library working group chair, who lives like a couple blocks away from me, yesterday. And Nicole from the VC package team and I went and got bagels for breakfast today. That was fun. It's nice to be in the big city. Those second-class New York bagels.
不过，进展顺利。是的，我来这儿才一个星期。和一大群不同的 C++ 伙伴一起吃饭。昨天我和前图书馆工作组主席阿拉斯泰尔一起吃了晚饭，他就住在离我几个街区远的地方。今天我和 vcpkg 团队的妮可去吃了个百吉饼早餐。挺有意思的。能在大城市的感觉真好。那些二流的纽约百吉饼。
Really? You want to go there? You want to start this? I'm just saying that to ruffle your feathers. I don't even understand the bagel debate to the bagel war. Well, it's very simple. In Canada, they produce bread rings that they do not, my understanding is they do not like properly fry ahead of time. They just like bake like savages. them bagels, which is just wrong. And in New York, real authentic bagels are manufactured. And many of the best bagel places are the, you know, the historically Jewish little shops,
真的吗？你想挑起事端吗？你想开始这个话题吗？我这么说只是为了惹恼你。我甚至搞不懂关于百吉饼的争论和百吉饼大战。好吧，这很简单。在加拿大，他们生产的面包圈，据我所知，他们并没有提前正确地煮过。他们就像野蛮人一样直接烘烤。他们叫它百吉饼，这简直大错特错。而在纽约，正宗的百吉饼是精工细作的。许多最好的百吉饼店都是那些历史悠久的犹太小店，
which produce bagels in the way that they did back in the bakeries in Poland. So these are real authentic bagels. Bagels are from Poland? Yeah. And have you ever had a Bialy? I once again have never even heard of the word Bialy. Really? I've heard of a Bianchi.
它们制作百吉饼的方式和当年波兰面包店里的一模一样。所以这些才是真正正宗的百吉饼。百吉饼来自波兰？对。你吃过比亚利面包（Bialy）吗？我再次连“比亚利”这个词都没听说过。真的吗？我听说过比安奇（Bianchi）。
A Bianchi? I think that's an italian bike it's um it's it's similar to a bagel um uh i i i don't i don't entirely know the difference but i think that bialy's have less flour in the bagel. Um, yeah. I'm not entirely sure what the difference is. Unlike a bagel, which is boiled before baking, a biali is simply baked, and instead of a hole in the middle, it has a depression.
比安奇？我想那是一辆意大利自行车。它……它有点像百吉饼……呃，我……我不太清楚具体的区别，但我觉得比亚利面包的面粉比百吉饼少。嗯，是的。我不太清楚具体区别在哪。与百吉饼在烘烤前需要先煮沸不同，比亚利面包只需直接烘烤，而且中间没有洞，只有一个凹陷。
Yeah, so like it's, and usually they put some stuff in the hole in the middle. Like, uh, some, uh, uh some like um caramelized onions or good stuff like that okay so so so the the canadian quote unquote bagel is probably closer to a bialy because it's not uh it's not boiled. It's simply baked. Well, next time I come down to New York, now that we're on the same time zone,
对，所以它……通常他们会在中间的洞里放点东西。比如，一些……一些焦糖洋葱或类似的好东西。好吧，所以加拿大的所谓“百吉饼”可能更接近比亚利面包，因为它没有煮过。它只是直接烘烤的。好吧，下次我下纽约去的时候，既然我们在同一个时区了，
yeah, welcome to EST or EDT or whatever we're on. Yeah. You can introduce me to whatever, the proper New York bagel. I've had New york bagels bialy is definitely 100 um polish because they're named for the polish city of bialy stock or whatever i'm sure i pronounced that wrong i'm sure all of our polish listeners Polish listeners, mostly the one that works for me, will be composing to me on Slack a message right now explaining how I just butchered the pronunciation of that.
耶，欢迎来到 EST 或 EDT 或我们所在的什么时间。你可以带我去见识一下正宗的纽约百吉饼。我吃过纽约的百吉饼。比亚利面包绝对 100% 是波兰的，因为它们是以波兰城市比亚韦斯托克（Bialystok）或类似的名字命名的，我确信我发音错了。我确信我们所有的波兰听众——波兰听众，主要是那个为我工作的家伙——现在就会在 Slack 上给我发信息，解释我是怎么把那个词的发音给搞砸的。
Does Mihal listen to this? I don't know. I don't think so. He's currently on vacation, so I think it's unlikely that he's listening to this one. Yeah. Right. But I'm pretty sure that Bagel is also, yeah, I'm almost certain Bagel's original origins are Poland.
米哈尔（Mihal）听这个节目吗？我不知道。我觉得不听。他目前在休假，所以我认为他听这期节目的可能性不大。对吧。不过我很确定百吉饼也是……是的，我几乎可以肯定百吉饼最初起源于波兰。
Yeah. The Polish Jews. So, sorry, Canadians. You don't get to claim this one. I mean, I wasn't trying to. I was just, I know that's like a thing that happens on Twitter that I don't understand. So, I mean, I like food. Yeah.
是的。波兰犹太人。所以，抱歉，加拿大人。你们不能把这个功劳揽过去。我的意思是，我本来也没想争。我只是……我知道这是推特上经常发生但我看不懂的事情。所以，我是说，我喜欢食物。对。
One bagel's, I guess one bagel is not as good as the next bagel. That's correct. Proper bagels have to be produced in, you know, in New York. I mean, I guess Poland also probably makes better bagels have to be produced in, you know, in New York. I mean, I guess Poland also probably makes. Yeah, man. You need that New York water. You need that New York water. Makes them better. It's actually completely a myth. It's not. It's not at all true. I didn't even know that was a myth. Learning so much today.
一个百吉饼，我猜一个百吉饼不如另一个百吉饼好。没错。正宗的百吉饼必须产于……你知道的……纽约。我的意思是，我猜波兰大概也能做出……正宗的百吉饼必须产于……你知道的……纽约。我的意思是，我猜波兰大概也能做出……是的，伙计。你需要纽约的水。你需要纽约的水。让它们变得更好。这其实完全是个神话。不是的。完全不是真的。我甚至不知道那是个神话。今天学到了好多。
Bialy's, Credenza's, apparently New York Water. There's a myth about bagels. Oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait. We didn't even get to the end of my story about my struggles in setting up the microphone. So I finally had the microphone assembled and then I go into the, I'm trying to figure out which room will have the least echo
比亚利面包、餐具柜，显然还有纽约的水。关于百吉饼还有一个神话。哦，哦，哦，等等，等等，等等。我们还没讲完我组装麦克风时历经艰难险阻的故事的结尾。所以我终于把麦克风组装好了，然后我走进……我试图弄清楚哪个房间的混响最少，
and I go into the bedroom. There's still a pretty substantial echo. I wasn't going to do the Connor thing, though. The Connor thing would have been to produce this podcast episode in my closet. I mean, you should consider it. You should consider it. People are going to be like, yeah, Bryce, your audio quality has dropped. You all can wait a week or two for my mammoth couch to get clear to dampen the sound like relax
然后我走进了卧室。回声还是相当严重。不过我可不会做出康纳那种事。康纳的做法会是在我的衣橱里录制这期播客节目。我的意思是，你应该考虑一下。你应该考虑一下。大家会觉得：“耶，布莱斯，你的音质下降了。”你们大家可以等上一两周，等我那张庞大的沙发运到好用来吸收声音，放松点，
relax but then I realized because the way I have the microphone configured I don't know if you can see it and I'm now lifting it up which is gonna make the audio quality a lot worse
放松点。但后来我意识到，因为我配置麦克风的方式——我不知道你能不能看到，我现在把它举起来了，这会让音质变得更糟，
but as you can see it's a little bit top heavy. So the first thing I tried to do was to put it just on my bed, which I will do now. And as you can see, it just falls right over. Again, not great for the audio quality in this episode. So I'm like, all right, it's okay. I'll just put it on my laptop keyboard so then i start doing that but then i realized i had to like carefully balance it to not like be smashing a bunch of keys but uh i think i've figured that out now so we can uh we can now proceed proceed with recording our episode an hour and uh 45 minutes in 45 minutes in 45 minutes of which 28
但如你所见，它有点头重脚轻。所以我尝试做的第一件事就是把它直接放在我的床上，我现在就这么做。如你所见，它直接倒了。再次声明，这对这期节目的音质不太友好。所以我心想，好吧，没关系。我把它放在我的笔记本电脑键盘上。然后我开始这么做，但接着我意识到我必须小心翼翼地保持平衡，免得砸到一堆按键。不过……我想我现在已经搞定了，所以我们可以……我们可以继续录制我们的节目了，节目已经进行了一个小时……呃……45分钟了。已经进行45分钟了，其中有28
minutes you were late you got to fix your camera too now I'm just staring at your mic but yeah it's the first time since July we didn't we didn't record a single episode in August hang on I got it you got it you got to see this you got to see this yes we didn't record a single episode.
分钟你都在迟到。你也得修修你的摄像头了，现在我一直盯着你的麦克风。不过，是的，这是自七月以来我们第一次……我们在八月一期节目都没录。等一下，我拿到了。你拿到了。你得看看这个，你得看看这个。耶，我们一期节目都没录。
Watch this. This is my favorite feature of the apartment. Okay. It's a remote control shades. It brings me great joy. It brings me great joy. It brings me great joy. The bathroom has a heated seat. A heated floor, which is very nice.
看这个。这是我这套公寓里最喜欢的功能。好吧。它是遥控遮阳帘。这给我带来了巨大的快乐。这给我带来了巨大的快乐。这给我带来了巨大的快乐。浴室里有加热马桶圈。有地暖，这非常棒。
That is very nice, especially in the winter. And I'm pretty sure that the Mexican consulate is like right across the street from me because I'm pretty sure it's the Mexican flag that's flying from the top of it. Is that something you look for in property when uh i mean i i am quite near the uh the un actually no maybe i'm wrong maybe it's the italian
这真的很棒，特别是在冬天。而且我相当确定墨西哥领事馆就在我街对面，因为我确信飘扬在它顶上的是墨西哥国旗。这是你在找房子时会注意的东西吗？呃……其实我离联合国挺近的……其实不对，可能我弄错了，也许那是意大利的……
it's the it's the colors of the mexican flag but it's not exactly the mexican flag it's yeah i don't know what flag has red white and green in horizontal stripes i want to say hungary you think it's hungary no i'm checking up hungary flag if i get this right that'll be oh damn that's exactly correct um but there's nothing in the middle is there like a little emblem in the middle uh or is it just there's no little little emblem yeah i nailed it god damn look at that wow hungry yeah mexico is uh vertical with like a little yeah yeah little bird wow so that must be the Hungary. No. That can't be it. Because the size of that building.
那是墨西哥国旗的颜色，但又不完全是墨西哥国旗，是……呃，我不知道什么国旗是红、白、绿水平条纹的。我想说是匈牙利。你觉得是匈牙利吗？不，我查一下匈牙利国旗。如果我猜对了，那就……哦，天哪，完全正确。中间没有东西，对吧？中间没有小徽标吗？还是说……没有小徽标。耶，我猜对了，天哪，看看这个！哇，匈牙利。对，墨西哥的是垂直条纹的，带着一个小……对，小鸟。哇，那一定就是匈牙利。不对。那不可能是匈牙利。因为那栋楼的规模……
Look, no offense to the great nation of Hungary. But I don't think that Hungary has quite so much real estate. Can you stop offending all of our listeners in different countries? You've offended Canada. You've offended Hungary. You were nice to Poland. That was nice. Although you probably mispronounced. Yeah, I probably offended the Polish in some way.
听着，对伟大的匈牙利国没有任何不敬的意思。但我不认为匈牙利有那么多的房地产。你能停止冒犯我们来自不同国家的听众吗？你已经冒犯了加拿大。你已经冒犯了匈牙利。你对波兰挺好的。那挺不错。虽然你可能发音不标准。对，我可能在某种程度上冒犯了波兰人。
At ADSP, the podcast, I, Connor Hoekstra, apologize on behalf of all panelists or hosts that may or may not have offended your people. Speaking of what, what, what's the country where we were, where we were very popular. Oh, it was either. I think it was Slovakia. Slovakia. Yeah. We were like, we were like the number 17 podcast. I thought it was Slovenia. Or was it Slovenia? Oh God. We should probably know this
在 ADSP 播客中，我——康纳·霍克斯特（Connor Hoekstra），谨代表可能冒犯或未冒犯过你们国家的全体小组嘉宾或主持人向大家道歉。说到这个，我们非常受欢迎的国家是哪个来着？哦，要么是……我觉得是斯洛伐克。斯洛伐克。对。我们当时就像是……我们就像是排名第 17 的播客。我以为是斯洛文尼亚。还是斯洛文尼亚？天哪。我们大概应该知道这个的……
we also apologize to our either slovenian or slovakian listeners but yeah we were the we were like we're just ignorant americans it's been over it's been over a month since we've done this so clearly uh we're a bit out of practice uh or at least we're gonna blame it on bryce because what are you talking about this is going great i'm glad you think so so we should probably talk about some code yeah yeah yeah let's uh well first so we'll we'll end it there and then we'll start our new we'll start our new actual technical podcast so that last one was episode 41. I apologize to listeners. That's the title of the episode. I apologize to listeners. Yeah, I apologize to listeners or like Bryce can't set up a microphone, something like that, I think might be good. Because that was the overarching narrative that was told throughout.
我们也向我们的斯洛文尼亚或斯洛伐克听众道歉。不过，是的，我们就像……我们只是一群无知的美国人。我们已经有一个多月没做这个了，所以很显然……我们有点生疏了……或者至少我们要把这归咎于布莱斯，因为你在说什么呢，进展得很顺利。我很高兴你这么觉得。所以我们大概应该聊聊代码了。对，对，好吧，首先……我们先聊到这儿，然后我们将开始我们的新……我们将开始我们的真正技术播客。所以刚才那一期是第 41 期。我向听众道歉。这就是本期节目的标题。我向听众道歉。是的，“我向听众道歉”或者像“布莱斯搞不定麦克风”，诸如此类的，我觉得可能挺不错的。因为那是贯穿始终的主线故事。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。